there's a Native American proverb that
says the one who tells the story rules
the world stories have the potential to
be incredibly powerful they're able to
change how we relate to each other to
change prejudice so the potential for
stories to persuade is staggering I read
this really really good research paper
about these two books which basically
suggested that if you get people to read
a couple of chapters of Harry Potter
they'll rate themselves higher than
other people in their ability to
potentially move something just using
the power of their mind but people who
read about the vampires they'll actually
believe that their teeth are slightly
longer than other people in the
population just as a result of having
read a chapter or two of this book in
terms of psychology there's a few things
that stories actually do to us we get
this sense that we're fully immersed in
the world that we're reading about we
start to almost feel as if the things
that are happening to them are happening
to us
[Music]
reading is not a relaxation you are
building worlds you are populating those
worlds with cities and those cities you
are populating with people so although
television film theater or have their
place in the storytelling world to me
that moment of contact with a book when
you read a story and unlock its secrets
nothing quite comes close our research
has been on the meaning of individual
words if you read the word jump for
example you activate those areas that
you also activate when you do actually
perform the action of jumping so there
could be about about here somewhere the
interesting question in this case of
course is I mean if you read about
somebody else
jumping why should you activate brain
areas related to jumping
[Music]
the proponents of the theory would say
that immersing yourself into a story is
based on the mirror neuron system I am
convinced that mirror neurons are part
of this process but it can be the whole
story
it's being fooled that when we connect
with people who aren't real but are
fictional characters it forms a sort of
social surrogate for us it's always like
they're a real person when they're not
and psychologists sometimes call it
forming a flower social relationship and
what's interesting about that is it kind
of makes us feel less alone Lee and it
can also prefer self-esteem and improve
our mood we know that having a lot of
friendships with other people when
you're in a couple it's a really
positive thing for the outcomes of that
relationship but what's really
interesting is they don't have to be
real people if you're trying to change
people's opinions about controversial
topics such as same-sex marriage or
immigration for example but stories have
actually been found to be a lot more
effective in producing political change
[Music]
attitudes towards stigmatized groups
could be improved by reading Harry
Potter but only if the person identified
with Harry
children love stories they always have a
story to tell whether it's about the
weekend or what happened in the
playground and it's such an important
part of understanding the world around
them and understanding themselves
you should definitely turn this off
right now and go and pick up a book
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon